[Musique]
sous violemment sa nou camp courant des
ailes à manquer et voyages des dents et
mater jeunes
les réunionnais ont eu rendez vous avec
leur histoire au jardin de l'état pour
les 20 ans du réseau car jaune
dès les premiers pas l'histoire du
transport local fait remonter les
souvenirs
depuis 1996 le département a pris en
main la politique départementale de
transport on est ici ok c'est un village
un village festif pour cette journée
pour ses 20 ans car jaune donc on
commence avec une exposition qui retrace
toute l'histoire du transport mais
surtout du quart jeunes donc depuis
l'histoire du tour depuis le début
d'histoire de transport jusqu'à
aujourd'hui et surtout ça peut vraiment
sur les vingt ans car jaune donc de la
naissance en 1996 à aujourd'hui donc
[Musique]
ce village aux jeux lontan a mis toute
la famille dans une ambiance de partage
intergénérationnel
du quart courants d'air ou nouveaux
véhicules à étages c'est la même
génération de voyageurs s'inviter 55 81
57 d'accord l'avait inventée par john
coucher
était pas trop serré avant
[Musique]
vous établissez la venue saluer
oui ben là mais va ça mais dès qu'on
pense justement que ce service eau pour
les clients un service de 11
mois la réunion avance le modem
mais parce que quand le mari pépin à
manama mais prend le bus que ça en vie
et oui et puis c c'est une autre chose
comme cela lui est un peu leur liberté
des gens souriants qui rencontre du
personnel fier de partager leur métier
de l'ombre voilà ce qui a rythmé la
journée un cadre idéal pour faire passer
des messages avec la démographie
qui évolué avec les raisons qui devait
s'accentuer
on conviendrait que la stratégie qui
avait été adoptée en 1996 ne correspond
plus aux données actuelles que nous
avons on ne touche plus le même public
le réseau évolué le réseau est devenu
moderne performant nous voulons qu'il
soit encore plus attractif pour
justement pallier à deux problématiques
la problématique du tout voiture il a
promis d la problématique de
l'engorgement routier
[Musique]
2 5 millions de voyageurs par an près de
8 millions de kilomètres parcourus dans
l'île 170 conducteurs 139 arrêt le car
jaune est partout
[Musique]
tradition pays
de la région ont fait parler d'eux
résumé
la casse
[Musique]